مجاعات الحروب حتى الطاعون الدبلي ، فإن
حانة كوكس القتال القديمة في سانت ألبانز
إنكلترا التي تدعي أنها أقدم
حانة في بريطانيا قد عاشت من خلالها جميعًا
وفقًا لموقعها على الإنترنت ، فإن الأنابيب هي
الحانة تعمل منذ
إعلان 793 مما يجعلها جميلة  قديم
لكن آثار covet أثبتت
الكثير بالنسبة لحفرة الري بعد أكثر
من مائة عام ،
إنها تغلق أبوابها
وتنضم إلينا الآن كريستو توفالي هو
مالك ومشغل
حانة القتال القديمة كوكس ،
فليس هناك حقًا طريقة أخرى ليست كذلك  هناك
أي شيء يمكنك القيام به لإبقائه مفتوحًا ،
هذا هو السؤال عن
اللحظة التي سيحدث فيها صباح الخير ، إنه لشرف
وسعادة أن أكون معك ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على الاتصال بنا ، إنه
السؤال عن اللحظة التي
سيحدث فيها.
حاليًا يمكنني أن أقول إنني كنت على
الهاتف طوال الصباح
مع
العديد من الأطراف المختلفة بما في ذلك
بشكل رئيسي المسؤولين أو الذين يعملون من
أجلنا ،
إنه وضع شديد الانسيابية.
شاهد المشاعر القلبية في
جميع أنحاء العالم
أه بالنسبة لنا وقد زارها والعديد
منكم الذين يعلقون من جميع أنحاء
العالم بالفعل ، لذا
كانت تجربة متواضعة
ولكنها حالة مائعة أود
التحدث عنها جميعًا
ولكن
إنه يحدث كثيرًا ، لقد تواصل معه
أي شخص وقال إنك تعرف
ما الذي يمكننا القيام به ، هل يمكننا تمويل جماعي ،
هذا هناك شيء ما جاريًا ، ما رأيك ،
ما الذي لديك ،
ما هو ردك ،
كان هناك أشخاص على أه لديهم أه
أنشئ موقعًا للتمويل الجماعي مع
السكان المحليين ، لقد أخبرتهم بالفعل أنني
لا أستطيع أخذ المال
لأنهم يفعلون ما أود فعله
بالحانة وما كنت أخطط لفعله مرة أخرى
خلال الـ 25 عامًا التالية التي
اشتريتها عندما كان عمري حوالي 40 عامًا ،
كان لدي 25 عامًا أخرى لأذهب إليها ، كان الأمر
يستحق التصرف مثل فاعل الخير
وقضاء السنوات الـ 25 التالية في إنشاء هذه
الحانة ، ويمكن أن تبقى
للألف سنة القادمة  لأنها n  في
الشكل الصحيح ، إنه مبنى قديم جدًا
ليس لدينا إمكانية الوصول لذوي الاحتياجات الخاصة ، وليس
لدينا منشأة معاقين بها مقعد ورافعة ،
فهي تحتاج إلى مطبخ أكبر ،
نحتاج إلى المزيد من الأرقام هناك لجعلها
قابلة للتطبيق من الناحية المالية وآمنة
للألف سنة القادمة لكن